Film Courage: How is an episode of television
structured and has it changed over the
years? Bruce Ferber, Author/Former Showrunner/Screenwriter: Well it's changed over the years
because more of the sitcoms are single
camera so in the old days really at the
beginning of the multi-camera not the
very beginning of I Love Lucy but let's say
when I was working at Paramount and most
of those shows would have maybe six
scenes and you would and it was only two
acts today you have three acts and if
you still on a network with commercials
you have well the offices I don't know
maybe it's even more than three it'll be
three acts with a teaser and a tag so
there's tons of commercials everywhere
that of course people are you know
zipping through so in the old days you
just really wanted a great at break so
you know when you only have two acts so
an act break would kind of be a sort of
a cliffhanger where you want people to
come in after the commercial that was
the way that worked so then they started
making the running time of network shows
shorter I think when I started they were
24 minutes now they're probably under 21
minutes so there's a lot of commercial
time and they break it all up so what I
think the network's want is instead of
one reason for people to come back they
want like four or five reasons for
people to come back and most of the time
honestly it doesn't happen because if
you're doing 21 minutes of content
how many cliffhangers and you have in 21
minutes of contact content so that's why
if you watch a network show today you'll
see seams cut off and you'll be like god
that's so annoying and and because I got
to get all these commercial breaks in
which is why people love non network
television because they can actually
take a breath and and not even have to
grab the remote to go through the
commercials sorry what is a teaser and
what is it I'm sorry
teaser usually is a scene at the
beginning which is maybe it can be
anywhere from two to two and a half
pages it's just a little quick nugget it
may not even have to be on story that is
just before the main title or before the
the first scene and something that's
quick and pops with a big joke at the
end that that grabs the audience and a
tag is pretty much the show is over and
then they'll do maybe a one-minute scene
you know it could be after the wrap up
it's just something that might go into
the end credits so you want a big joke
at the end of that too and then it goes
into the to the end credits so this is
all stuff that doesn't need to exist it
all has to do with commercial breaks
you